so Tony I saw you outside we talked said
I think you're gonna win tonight and you
looked at me like a crazy person you
looked at me like a mad man and we did
your winning face how would would it
that what was that moment like when I
called your name you know when I don't
know if everybody experiences this but
when I'm out there and they're they're
announcing the category and the names
and then they announced they then the
winner is and then all of a sudden like
my ears I feel like like I'm in a wind
tunnel and I actually don't hear my name
I don't I don't actually hear it so I'm
struggling to like read the lips and I'm
wondering you know what I mean I just
might yours like go kind of wonky on me
and busted he was high but it's uh it's
a weird it's a real kind of yeah it's a
little bit of an out-of-body thing so
then I just stand up and hope that I was
right but they did say my name you've
been down this road before so she's been
down a lot of Rights
hey but so is it so do you still feel
that rush when you it was a shot it was
insane and I threw up a little backstage
did you yeah it was it was very shocking
I had $100 on Olivia Colman no come on
no actually I
I made an online vet I'm Olivia Colman
and I lost $100 that was that confident
she was gonna win Wow Wow
we have a gift for you because we feel
it's a hundred dollars is it my own
vomit from backstage it's something even
better
just in case you do the plunger the
magic plunger from et is this used from
your own home not my home but our
facilities and I want your plunger oh no
you don't want that plunger this is very
strange and I can only blame Amy
sherman-palladino that for the rest of
my life I will be associated with hogs
crap from a toilet you know I think I
you hold on I'll take this I'll take it
and you just take that and I'd like to
thank well what if I do this
all the Academy all okay
oh this now I know it's going in the
bathroom I've got a place for this now
thank you Tony
you're welcome I do have to ask you what
is the magic mix of this little show
that makes it so damn close even Susie
right there I think you know it's nice
about that should the nicest thing is
it's a bunch of professional grown-ups
on our set we are all we are all kind of
dedicated grown-ups on that set and
everyone comes super prepared because it
is very difficult show to do the lines
the amount of lines the dialogue the
content and and everyone brings their a
game
no one is unprepared and it's it's
that's I think a huge part I mean the
writings but then everyone's coming
prepared to deliver it yeah it's true
it's really almost like a it's like a
doing theater in a way live stage
performance don't you think you're all
just super focused and keyed into each
other hanging on for dear life and you
know and kind of leaning into each other
and it just makes for a great workout
atmosphere even when we have scenes with
a lot of coverage where you could relax
and just do your lines on one side
everyone who wants to still do it like a
theatrical we all want it to be a
complete scene so you get the reality
and that's rare all right you guys got a
go but before you go I mean where's the
party tonight
are you parties at your house no really
I'm coming to your bring the plunger
whatever you do I bring a plunger I'm
coming there are several parties and I
will announce the addresses on my
Instagram no really will you absolutely
there's one at jeff bezos place there's
one Aimee and Dan's place there's one at
Tony's place yeah I want to go to Bezos
house um can you can you give me the
address absolutely it's one two one two
boogie-woogie Avenue
that was for my kids
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]